bonsoir bonsoir tout le monde je suis
très très heureux d'être parmi vous
j'aurais pu être parmi vous il ya 25 ans
j'ai fait un peu le même cursus que vous
j'ai d'ailleurs postuler à paris à
l'époque paris du moins pas rien moi
j'étais à paris un à l'époque deux fines
il fallait voir une mention je sais pas
c'est toujours le cas et j'ai fait un
bac b le bag le plus passable donc le
bac économie et donc j'ai été recalé
dans votre fac et j'ai fais pas rien
donc tolbiac panthéon en cinq ans j'ai
fait deux premières années je savais pas
du tout où j'allais ce que j'allais
faire j'ai suivi des copains donc
j'aurais pu faire gestion droit ou en
tout cas j'ai suivi cette voie pour
essayer de trouver quelque chose est en
tout cas étant le fils aîné de trois de
trois enfants montrer à ma mère mes
parents que quelque part
j'allais pouvoir faire les choses de ne
pas trop mauvais voilà je voulais vous
parler de mon job en tout cas de mon
aventure celle que qui a fait que je
suis devenu galeriste alors que j'étais
pas du tout prix disposer je vous dis
que j'ai fait une maîtrise d'économie
donc pas du tout quelque chose qui me
permettait de prétendre à devenir
grévistes mais en fait
et peut-être que vous êtes certain dans
ce cas de figure en visant
après le bac quelques études on sait pas
trop quoi faire ou en tout cas vers quoi
tendre et c'était mon cas en licence
j'ai eu un petit job j'ai vendu des
lithographies en porte à porte et pour
avoir un peu d'argent de poche et je
m'étais dit c'est ce truc là que je vais
faire dire que c'était un monde qui
était complètement abstrait pour moi je
savais pas du tout ce que j'allais ça
défile je crois le tpiy diamant donc ça
c'est mes débuts j'avais j'avais donc
quinze ans - j'avais des cheveux j'ai un
peu moins maintenant et mais je m'étais
dit que quelque part il fallait que je
puisse accéder à une sorte de rêve une
sorte de fantasme me dire que même si je
ne viens pas d'un milieu où la culture
était présente
je sentais quelque chose qui m'obsédait
et je me disais j'avais envie de devenir
un galeriste d'avoir un prof galerie
rencontrer les artistes
donc quelque chose qui s'offrait à moi
et qui était devenu une évidence en tout
cas j'étais devenu sur comment j'allais
réussir à devenir riche savais pas mais
en tout cas j'étais sûr de ce postulat
donc j'ai 23 ans je fais pas de
troisième cycle je m'arrête en maîtrise
alors que tous mes copains faisait ddv
16 ou d ea et à l'époque sous mitterrand
mitterrand et merci mitterrand fils et
43 mille francs pour les créateurs
d'entreprise voilà donc j'ai monté ce
une escale avec un copain qui avait un
double tss de droit et donc on a eu on a
obtenu 86 mille francs donc ce qui
correspond à 15000 euros à peu près et
on a monté une petite essai réel et on a
commencé à faire les centres commerciaux
donc au niveau le plus bas possible
puisqu'on n'avait aucune connaissance et
il fallait que moi je convaincre mon
copain de continuer à persévérer de ne
pas lâcher le truc est de commencer un
petit peu à essayer d'atteindre ces
artistes qui me faisait qui me fascinait
donc au bout de un ou deux ans on sait
c'est le boulot le plus ingrat parce que
tu pars à angoulême
lyon à brest dans les formules 1 c'est
parfois hyper désespérant pas ce que tu
dis que tu vaux rien du tout il ya des
gens qui ont la même culture que toi
d'art c'est qu'on vendait des petites
révolutions qui valait 500 francs de
l'époque donc sans eau
donc c'était sans aucune prétention mais
quelque part il fallait qu'on puisse
survivre grâce à ce truc là au bout de
deux ans mon copain il laisse tomber il
se dit c'est pas possible il a continué
d'avancer devient grand et devient un
grand avocat d'affaires et moi je
m'étais dit que quelque part j'avais
envie de continuer j'avais envie de
persévérer sans toujours savoir où
j'allais aller
donc j'ai vraiment bouffer des pierres
pendant 7 8 ans en me disant que quelque
part il fallait que j'y arrive
et donc après angoulême brest où lyon ou
nantes je prenais quelques jours à paris
et j'allais visiter ces galeries où je
comprenais rien du tout mais je me
disais que c'était le monde dans lequel
je serai bientôt j'espère que ça vous
parle parce que je crois vraiment à
cette notion que l'obsession ne pas
lâcher si j'étais pas devenu galeriste
je pense que je serais devenu maire de
meurtriers j'aurais pas pu faire un
autre métier j'avais vraiment une envie
c'était 25 26 ans comme tous les mecs à
18 19 ans sortait en boîte
voilà à ce moment là je rencontre ma
femme qui a 16 ans et demi ce qui est
toujours ma femme on a cinq enfants et
j'avais dit un truc j'ai dit tu verras
tu t'es pas miec le dernier des derniers
tu verras ce sera un bon cheval
alors que je sais pas du tout exactement
quelle était en fait les horizons
possibles mais je m'étais dit que
quelque part ne pas insister et d'être
constamment dans la persévérance me
permettrait peut-être de deux d'accéder
à ce rêve
donc je vous la fait courte parce que
sinon je pourrais parler pendant des
heures on est en 1999 après dix années
de son commerciaux et donc de en fait
des année très très difficile parce que
quand tu sais que tel potentiel pour
avoir en tout cas pour être l'assistant
manial rist ou d'être de pouvoir servir
le café à quelqu'un qui permet de
comprendre de l'enseigné moi j'avais pas
les clés puisque en fait c'est un monde
très très clivant l'art c'est un monde
où en fait de cotation
en fait il ya peu d un petit monde qui
ceux qui se ressemblent qui se rassemble
et qui ceux qui discutent entre eux en
fait moi je n'avais pas du tout ce
dernier ces dernières clés qui me
permettait d'accéder à ce monde des
galeries donc j'allais à la fiac c'était
en fait tous ces événements de d'art
contemporain et j'apprenais par coeur
toutes les galeries une par une
je les scanne est on exactement savoir
qui étaient les différents acteurs les
différentes galeries et qui étaient les
différents artistes sans savoir en me
disant que quelque part on habitait
porte de vanves et à la porte de vanves
y avait un acteur toujours un petit
marché aux puces qui vend de la brocante
et ma femme elle adorait la brocante et
moi je la laisse est regardée de la
brocante et moi j'ai acheté les petits
catalogues qui valait 20 balles 30 prend
40 francs et qui me permettaient les
petits catalogues de vente public qui me
permettait d'apprendre jour par coeur et
de pouvoir voir les clés qui me
permettrait à terme est de pouvoir un
jour prétendre à cette gare est donc on
en 98 en 98 dernière édition de la fiac
je me balade avec ma femme est là au
bout d'un moment n'était pas devant
l'époque
à l'époque la fiac étaient allés à
l'endroit de du musée du quai branly
donc sur les sous une tente et j'ai le
souvenir d'avoir eu une sorte de moment
particulier qui me faisait dire que si
ça n'arrivait pas j'aurais pu devenir
quelqu'un de criminels et il fallait que
ça arrive on est marché de la fiac
jusqu'à la maison et je m'étais dit que
si ça arrivait pas l'année suivante et
se serait passé quelque chose de
terrible terrible vous dire le mec il un
peu barge mais c'est une vraie histoire
donc on marche je dis à ma femme anika
écoutes ne parle pas on a marché du quai
branly jusqu'à la porte de vanves à pied
et moi dans ma tête je me disais c'est
pas possible il faut que ça arrive et
donc parfois je crois beaucoup à la
fatalité
thaddée des portes qui s'ouvrent et je
pense que dans la vie il ya ce paramètre
important la chance et avoir un moment
où il faut rentrer dans le truc parce
que sinon si tu rentres pas battue reste
à quai
ce moment là c'est un et copains qui
étaient collant des affiches que c'était
le niveau que j'étais me dis qu'il ya un
espace qui s'ouvre rue mazarine dans le
quartier où je suis actuellement qui est
fermé depuis 15 mois le type qui était
juste avant moi n'avait pas payé son
loyer et donc le propriétaire avait fait
jouer la clause de réseaux sociaux mbaye
il avait viré le deal qui lui avait
promis avant de virer il lui avait dit
écoute
trouve moi un éventuel client qui
pourrait éventuellement louer cet espace
et je te filerai un petit quelque chose
donc la personne
je vais les rencontrer et elle me dit
que si je lui donne 70 mille francs de
l'époque
il présenterait le propriétaire de des
murs et donc je pourrais avoir ma
galerie
j'ai pas dormi de la nuit je me suis dit
est-ce que ce mec qui me raconte
est-ce que c'est du baratin est-ce que
c'est sérieux et en fait je m'étais dit
quelque part je ne risquais rien j'y
suis allé j'ai réuni avec mon frère et
ma mère soixante dix mille francs
et donc j'ai filé sa au mec qui m'a
effectivement présenter monsieur lafarge
qui était le propriétaire qui m'a fait
confiance et qui m'a dit qu'est ce que
vous allez faire je vais faire une
grande galerie alors que la galerie
faisait vers mètres carrés j'avais pas
du tout ce que j'allais faire comme
programme donc quelque part je me disais
j'ai ma galerie mais j'avais aucune
programmation le quartier où on était
c'est un quartier essentiellement
constitué de galeries d'art déco ou de
galeries d'art primitif de vie galerie
d'art africain absolument pas de galerie
d'art contemporain et toute façon même
si je pouvais prétendre à vouloir faire
d'art contemporain j'avais pas le
j'avais pas la culture ou en tout cas
j'avais pas les connexions pour
présenter des artistes puis j'ai que je
couvre lit je présente donc pendant un
an dans mon quartier j'ai été vraiment
le mouton noir et un café qui s'appelle
vous allez peut-être la palette
j'y allais avec la tête baissée en me
disant jus cramer les types ils peuvent
pas me meut m'accepter comme un des
leurs et j'ai montré pendant un an
des peintures de la butte montmartre
dont qui était vraiment le niveau le
plus bas dans un quartier où un peu snob
ou les gens fêtent ce
10 et se fréquentent et rassemble au
bout d'un an quelque part je m'étais dit
qu'est ce que j'ai démontré en 2000 et
là je me dis en achetant des petites
publications de l'éditeur taschen
il y avait quelques magazines autour de
la photographie je m'étais dit que la
photographie n'était pas monté à paris
il fallait que je monte la photographie
on a commencé en fait à voyager à new
york au japon voir certains photographes
et que j'ai convaincu uniquement par le
fait que j'y suis allé au culot en me
disant que ces types là devait entendre
et en fait je leur ai vendu en fait
paris et pas kamel paris c'était ce
qu'il les invités n'ont pas la galerie
kamel mennour qui ne connaissait
absolument pas et en fait on a fait
venir des gens hyper célèbre assez
rapidement comme larry clark le le le le
cinéaste araki bon je vais pas vous
citer tous les noms en tout cas des
photographes qui avait vraiment une
vraie identité une vraie reconnaissance
du milieu et qu'on a montrées pendant
cinq six ans à la galerie ça du défilé
au fur et à mesure en fait on a fait ce
petit diaporama qui est une sorte de 2,2
de liste chronologique qui permet en
fait de montrer les débuts donc en 99 la
photographie jusqu'en 2005 2006 et
ensuite au bout d'un certain moment
l'accession dans certaines dans
certaines foires d'art la fiac la foire
de bâle dont qui sont en fait les les
événements les plus importants de du
monde de l'art et quelque part au bout
d'un moment
quand les gens voient qu'il ya une sorte
d'assistance est une sorte de volonté
complètement affirmé est complètement
volontaire les portes on commence à
s'ouvrir et j'ai commencé en fait à
rencontrer des artistes dans des squats
des artistes dans des ateliers à l'école
des beaux-arts qui est qui et qui est
vraiment pas loin de la galerie et au
bout d'un moment je devenais quelqu'un
qui pouvait être écoutés ou entendu j'ai
voulu vous raconter un petit peu en
diagonale cette histoire parce que il ya
25 ans tu ça je veux rappeler je me
rappelle très bien de mes cours en
amphithéâtre je me disais qu'est ce que
je fous ici en tout cas dans mon cas de
figure je ne trouvais pas en fait ma
voix en me disant que l'économie vers
quoi ça me ça m'amenait je ne voyais pas
faire de rentrer chez arthur andersen ou
en fait paribas ce n'était pas mon truc
je me disais qu'est ce que j'allais
faire
et en fait c'est au bout du compte ce
petit job 2 1 devant de lithographie qui
m'a fait penser que quelque part je
pouvais peut-être devenir galeriste est
en tout cas ce monde de l'art commençait
vraiment à me fasciner et commencé en
fait à me à me convaincre de cette
volonté d'arriver et de de pouvoir être
un partenaire des artistes que nous
défendons aujourd'hui donc maintenant
j'en parle avec un peu de recul ça fait
quinze ans on est on a deux espaces dans
le quartier on est toujours d'ailleurs
et on défend en fait une génération
émergente dont des jeunes artistes qui
démarre donc les artistes qui ont aucune
aucune visibilité aucune reconnaissance
et aucune qui sortent de là des
beaux-arts ou sinon en fait et c'est une
sorte de va et vient des artistes en
fête historique qu'ont que nous mettons
en fait en lumière par rapport à des
expositions qui ont qui leur permettent
en fait de revivez de 2 euros proposés
par rapport à l'histoire de l'art voilà
je sais pas si vous avez vu quelques
images qui paraissent donc là c'est
c'est françois molins qui a été montré
la dernière au centre pompidou qu'on a
montré la galerie très prochainement
d'ailleurs dimanche je vous invite à
voir il ya pas mal de polémiques en ce
moment sur un artiste qui va être
montreux château de versailles donc
l'art contemporain dans la tradition
anish kapoor monumenta avec plusieurs
expositions qu'on a défendu donc en fait
voilà j'ai voulu vous raconter une
histoire plutôt que vous racontez qu'est
ce qu'être galeriste j'ai voulu vous
raconter en fait le fait de 2,2 de
persévérer dans une sorte de volonté
d'arriver à quelque chose qui devient
une sorte de deux certitudes sans savoir
exactement et sans avoir les armes sans
avoir les codes sans avoir le
vocabulaire et sans avoir la grammaire
que j'ai acquis au fur et à mesure des
rencontres et grâce aux artistes grâce
aux journalistes et aux commissaires
d'exposition voilà